I cannot express how unbelievable it is
to me that I still get to do this
Taylor Swift shocks fan
ama's appearance she's about to win so
many awards tonight which I'm so excited
to see yeah Gail was spot on the
songstra snapped six nominations and six
wins for red Taylor's version and after
skipping the red carpet swifties
rejoiced when she was on stage to accept
her first award I cannot tell you how
much my re-recorded albums mean to me
that Magic's not here no more oh my gosh
yes Chris Stapleton and Phoebe Bridgers
like the just like the star players of
music right now like how lucky am I
there was a music video that I did that
I was really happy about
[Music]
so I want to say thank you to Sadie sink
and Dylan O'Brien
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
but honestly the actors Sadie and Dylan
I had a feeling if you put these two
people in a room and you trust their
instincts
magical things could happen they were
Electric in this I really just am so
proud of those performances I want to
take a moment to thank
um someone who directed the other music
video Blake Lively
[Music]
and
[Music]
the incredible Miles Teller and his
gorgeous wife Kelly teller for being in
the music video
is over
[Music]
it's hard to believe but of course it
wasn't taze only when Sunday night here
are the nominees for favorite music
video artist of the year I have the fans
to thank essentially
for my happiness
and I bet you think about me it was an
amazing experience and one of the things
about the whole discussion over music
ownership is that I know this was
something that started out as a really
hard thing I went through the fans are
the people who turned it into something
very empowering where when they they
were just saying to me over and over
again we want to listen to your versions
if you redo it that's what we'll listen
to I just wanted to think about what
could I do over the course of one week
that would make them as happy or try to
make them as happy as they've made me
foreign